it is Friday which means I have five of
this week's biggest stories all ready to
go for you to get you caught up on what
matters in gaming lipstick Microsoft has
said that demand for their 150 dollar
Xbox one elite controller has surpassed
our expectations Xbox boss bill Spencer
has been replying to fans who are after
the controller on Twitter saying we are
working to get more in stock sorry
they've been so hard to find when asked
by another person if they could get a
controller before Christmas he replied
it's tough as they don't want to over
promise the man has just exceeded our
planning if you find one and you want it
pick it up sorry the elite controller
launched at the end of October alongside
hero 5 guardians and we have an
impressions video up on gamespot if you
want to find out what we thought of it
and your technical analysis from digital
foundry has discovered that while the
ps4 version or just cause to look
slightly crisper than that on xbox one
that you are very similar after applying
the one point 01 update they found that
the ps4 edition runs at a native 1080p
while the xbox one version runs at 900p
they reported the birth versions we look
equivalent to the high setting on the PC
version of the game digital foundry said
that both console editions have issues
sustaining 30 frames per second although
the xbox one struggled more maintaining
30fps even in areas of the game which
were less intensive meanwhile on PC
Avalanche Studios have acknowledged a
bunch of graphical and technical
problems being reported by players and
have said they're committed to providing
a fix as soon as possible fallout 4 is
the open-world that keeps on giving and
now a player has discovered a mysterious
underwater structure after falling into
the sea sand player equipped power armor
eights of my look hex which lets you
breathe underwater and have
out along the ocean floor initially it
appeared as if there was just a lot of
sweet underwater flora down there but
then the player came across a large and
bronze building which appeared to be
some sort of pumping or water filtration
structure although it could not be
entered after last month's discovery of
an unneutered pen gun this is the second
hit which suggests that under water
content may have been previously planned
for the game ps4 games may be getting a
technical upgrade in future every rumor
about the console 7th Corps opening up
proved to be true at present the ps4
reserves 3.5 gigabyte of RAM and show
that eight cores per system memory
although this may be changing notes on
an update for the audio tool f mod
released in November read ps4 added F
mod red core sex to allow access to the
newly unlocked seventh Corps if this is
the case we could see future ps4 games
perform better as this allows developers
to use the 7th Corps to process more
operations in games Microsoft did a
similar thing with the xbox one earlier
this year
finally a very impressive GTA 5 PC mods
turned the game into a damn work of art
among other things the pinnacle of V mod
by Josh ramat Oh ads 4k textures
improved sound and even make gameplay
changes like improving weapon
destruction vehicle handling and
relationship dynamics between NP stays
the mobs description reads not only is
this a visual enhancement but literally
every aspect of the game has been
tweaked adjusted and fine-tuned to
create the most realistic stunning and
immersive Grand Theft Auto experienced a
date you can check out the fullness of
graphical and technical changes in our
story on gamespot let me know down in
that comment section what you cared
about this week and if you think the
Xbox one elite controller is worth the
money this week on site I tell you about
all the games that were keen on the
grappling hook this year on the gist
Lucy wraps up the story of Dark Souls on
in two minutes and we go over full axles
best mods that is everything I have for
you this week but as always be sure to
have yourself a great weekend and I will
catch your game on Monday